[Music]
alright guys in retail playground news
puh-leeze will call to Ikea after
thousands signed up for a game of
hide-and-seek they got a better turnout
then the people raid in area 51
September 21st I'm going are you going
are you in are you in I'll go I'll with
the camera cuz somebody has a document
but I'm not running toward [ __ ] good
I heard all the smells there are booked
out like all six rooms gotta make it
really easy for the cops to raid and
find them right after that's not good
they're like clearing out a whole entire
space just so people with campers can
come in like why would you give area 51
months of notice way too much they're so
stupid right
well dude dad you have to make sure
people could call off like work and life
months but like dude dig it and fly in
like whole military brigades and [ __ ]
get tanks and missiles alone the whole
thing is the element of surprise just
going in Naruto running maybe a little
you have a better shot yeah to me
surprise you'd be like oh well that's
new like it's not gonna be that much of
us so people get shot and everybody's on
me like I maybe we should reconsider
this whole [ __ ] same thing with Mike
Isis everybody has a plan until they get
punched in the mouth yeah yeah I can
plan all day to beat his ass he hit me
in the mouth I'm like what time up and I
didn't know we would hit that hard for
real let's get back to the article yeah
the police in Scotland were called to a
store after a Facebook group was set up
to plan an event a height of
hide-and-seek event and about 3,000
people signed up to it on Facebook and
so the police were standing there just
making sure there's no youth that looked
suspicious they would turn them away and
so that's what if you really needed a
buy a [ __ ] dress or some [ __ ]
like mainly like a teenager thing so as
soon as there were any teenagers that
didn't seem like they were there to buy
things but they didn't get to do the
hide-and-seek if they were good at it
and they would have never found illegal
about doing that that they have to call
the police no because then imagine you
as a consumer you're trying to shop
there and there are all these [ __ ]
kids like just imagine that but what's
illegal about that well if lautering
maybe not if you're not purchasing than
is law during they can ask you to leave
Frannie I would have been like wow this
is how sturdy their products are their
kids jumping all over this [ __ ] I can
totally imagine my kids in it on it or
assuming that all of this IKEA furniture
is keeping together and who the [ __ ] is
gonna be it for a thousand people to
have the tape they have to be like at
least a hundred people it if a thousand
people are playing is if this is one
[ __ ] I have to go around and find a
thousand ever played it at that scale
yeah quit somebody I think everyone's
wearing a blinker sweater and then you
just turn it on if you're it there
probably has to be a team of it's like
you can't be only one it has me I would
like to shoot a music video video in
IKEA that'd be cool music video or a
series like a web series so that way you
don't have to buy a kit you just go in
there I saw I remember reading or seeing
on YouTube or something but this someone
did do a web series type of [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
just using the different rooms was it
like a legit there was like a gorilla
gorilla would be like oh like someone's
just trying to cheap out on like
production and like that knob just been
that that's dumb as [ __ ] of your two
likes click subtly like just do I guys
we got a knock out three focuses a two
minutes
haha
that would be so dope everybody at the
go way in at different times who like
just meet in the office section did you
guys see that uh in China IKEA people
were just coming in and having full-on
[ __ ] siestas there in the place man
yeah and they're letting them yeah but
they're like it's funny do the pictures
they're just in the bed like it's their
own home not Disneyland you having stole
movie there so no I was at I was in
toontown with Tai Chi right and then in
toontown the [ __ ] like Mickey Mouse
bear or the Donald Duck bench yeah
there's just that asian lady laying in
there like it's made for the kids but I
guess for them though I'm tired I'm a
lay down she's just straight up taking
it after sleeping nobody's got a good
when it hits you got I saw a homeless
dude just lay down in middle street he
could he was caught right by the
sidewalk and he's just like right here
man this is where he's happening I was
like [ __ ] he must be tired
I saw almost dude faceplant like this
you're damn I'm kidding you he was like
completely gone whole and what and what
was crazy is I saw a cop pull a guy over
like 400 feet away for turning right
without a blinker and I'm like what
about the guy right there I don't even
know if he's alive
I wouldn't want ratings though if I was
a cop true true that no recently when we
were all eating something recently there
was a lady taking her lunch break there
and she just fell asleep like this she
must have been tired but then it got to
a point cause them to beginning sore
like this and then the moment I knew she
was really not that was because she was
like all the fall asleep oh man my
friend's garage maybe no that's not bad
on the back of a pickup truck in
Thailand while it was driving you got
kidding that bro you got to kidnap Korra
for me that's like oh the good nap
those best dad that was pretty hard yeah
I wasn't getting hit once Wow yeah man I
was high I was that tired head has never
been a really big thing for me because I
can't you jacking late from it so you
know I was sleepy and alcohol was
influencing it oh that makes sense
that's kind of like sleeping during a
massage or something it's so relaxing oh
you're standing up we see everybody fall
over the wall this was like wake up hit
my balls up cause if that balls man that
is way more painful than anything that
happened to me when I was in high school
I was getting hit in my truck what was
his name
it was not a guy it was a girl I'll have
you know I'm very defensive about that
and so yeah and I fell asleep but - but
after that every time I saw her I swore
that I didn't fall asleep I was just
really into it we're in New York you're
sucking is big and he fell asleep on top
what does that mean how bad you suck oh
let me finish so yeah I remember like we
I was like dude we gotta get this on so
we started going [ __ ] dick right now
we got to get this on the funny that's
first started dating yeah I mean yeah
yeah yeah yours on New Year's trip oh
wow what month was it I need to know so
then we were really really tired I
forgot what we did throughout the whole
day but I was just like listen I need to
get some dick so he told me he was
falling asleep because he's behind the
camera um he was like no I'm really
really sleepy and I'm like listen just
lay there oh no you on the book look
they're always going to be successfully
through money I got get an erection
while I'm sleep so long as he can do
that yeah you're good guy do get
erection I'm morning would you wake up
with it so long story I was just saying
yeah I had sex with the guy that was
asleep okay you said it like Casey did
that once I was giving him the best sex
of his life came right down the bag
adapt weren't you afraid that he was
gonna [ __ ] it do some sleep busting
sleep balls does that mean like [ __ ]
nut in his sleep what I mean the crane
pod doesn't dissolve yeah accidental
cream pies yeah not gonna make it a
thing Joe it's just one of my friends
now we see now this has to be a patreon
video because of you there's still a
percentage okay
yeah no one ever said it's true but
anyway we were talking about IKEA here
yeah I'd [ __ ] there you did well he was
reading my mind because I was thinking
about that okay that's good but you read
it do you ever eat the crawfish there
that's the real quick look that crawfish
they do it's [ __ ] crazy so you know
where their checkout line is you know
how there's another food area that the
frozen food yeah so in the bottom after
the check out there's like fridges there
and there's literally just vacuum packed
[ __ ] crawfish you never seen the
crawfish there I've seen a lot of other
frozen food
I wouldn't buy that I wouldn't buy
frozen seafood from afar and I got
busted for having horse meatballs yeah I
think so cuz they got worse okay because
I was about to say like I never got a
problem differ block yeah that's really
good though
is it mean there's a little bit sweeter
than he had horse meat in Japan in Japan
in real life yeah
it was actually pretty good oh I went to
solve South Korea and I saw that they
really like sale dog me like that dawg
like mmm Pomeranian or generally I think
I'm gonna go with Pomeranians if I did I
would go with what's the the k-9 dog
service yeah Malinois I would eat the
[ __ ] out of that all the years of a
night they call tear on black people
doing the civil rights movement dude
they have dog meat on the menu that's
insane and then he was like I'd be done
even free-range dog oh it's free range
though they sell it on the corner to
like like how they do it like hot dog
hot dog that is really like a hot dog
hot dog still like what are you doing
here like I I just had a lot like
regular fillets of sushi and fries the
McDonald's there they have like what is
it it's like a steak patty not fake I'm
sorry shrimp patty Oh like a deep-fried
shrimp patty that they have in
McDonald's I had that on the way to the
army base because I was doing a doing a
standard tour yeah for the USO so we did
South Korea Japan Tokyo Okinawa Kuna
and one other place awesome hey you got
some tattoos got bathed
this one right
life with this part of this was two
years ago 2017 over there yeah let's
find out
well fine I'll go back I wouldn't eat
dog dough
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]